on
dit que ce sont des persifleurs des
contestataires et même des emmerdeurs il
est vrai qu'ils n'ont pas leur langue
dans leur poche sont des empêcheurs de
tourner en rond sont des rebelles mais
rebelle à quoi quant à mon invité
d'honneur invités de référence est
invité pour le plaisir c'est le plus
célèbre des écologistes le papa de de
tous les écolos dont on parle beaucoup
et ans seul candidat à l'élection
présidentielle au titre des verts en
1974 cornelie
d'hiver n'existe pas enfin le groupe dès
que je trouve d'écologie rené dumont
déjà c'est il a bondi c'est alors rené
dumont 88 ans eut donc une énergie à une
une indignation deux jeunes hommes et je
me dis même que au bo l'âge finalement
au lieu peut-être de vous adoucir comme
ça vous a contraint j'ai l'impression
donnée plus de une capacité encore
supérieur d'indignation non je sais que
la situation devient d'autant plus grave
chaque année alors il faut qu'on
réagisse plus actuellement le sort de
l'humanité est en jeu si on ne réagit
pas brutalement dans quelques années
pour changer tout base d'utilisation
nous sommes perdus tout simplement mais
ça on ne le sait pas on sait qu'une
sécheresse terrible en afrique australe
personnes aux knicks et l'effet de serre
donc nos bagnoles donc nous a vus donc
notre gaspillage alors si on le sait les
médias ne nous permettent pas de donner
une information
répéter constante si on ne change pas
sur celle de fabriquer des grosses
voitures par exemple si on cesse de
faire des courses de moto avec les gars
qui se tuent ensuite au mans eh bien on
est perdu actuellement le sort du monde
oui mais on a quand même le sentiment
quand même que grâce à vous et à
beaucoup d'autres et pas seulement les
français talent et l'impression quand
même que ya une prise de conscience qui
se fait regarder les écologistes les
verts et les génération écolo ils ont
fait 15 % 2 des voix à eux deux vous
avez vu comment marie christine blandin
qui est devenue présidente du conseil
général du nord pas de calais sont des
succès ça j'étais là ça lui est
naturellement sa lancée mais les
dirigeants ne font rien actuellement le
times du 2 janvier 89 nous dit si on ne
l'interdît pas la fabrication de toutes
les autres consommant plus de 500
kilomètres on est perdu tout simplement
mais le times et c'est pas de revue clos
ses envies de l'islamisme en or
d'américains oui bon bain le français
qui dirige volkswagen nous a dit moi je
peux faire des voitures à 400 km si on
fait plus que ces voitures là nous
sommes perdus chaque année le co2
augmente l'effet de serre je reviens de
l'irak les maïs n'ont pas été faits
conduit 2 au 15 août c'est vrai parce
que la température est montée deux
degrés de plus dans les céréales
tropicale risque de arrêter la fondation
de ceux qui sont celles qui sont touchés
alors haussé paul nous avons la voiture
reste toujours votre bête noire non mais
là pardon tout les gaspillages d'énergie
pourquoi est-ce qu'on fait des courses
d'autos pouvoirs conférés par les
hackers maintenant séparés lock up
pourquoi est-ce que pourquoi est-ce
qu'on n'assassine par la voiture chaque
acheteur d'une grosse voiture est un
assassin ah oui mais là dites moi vous
êtes quand même pas venus ce soir en
vélo à vélo comme est devenu en métro a
donné en métro ou un morceau c'est pour
le moins
jeune et je n'ai plus l'auto j'avais une
auto qui ne circulait pas ce que pas un
jeu l'hégire lancé oui chacun peut le
faire peut en faire autant quand ils
habitent les environs de paris
mais vous pensez que la situation est
dramatique chaque année un peu plus
dramatique enfin nous venons
nous avons vu les jambes de femmes alors
est là pour les plus jeunes peut-être
qu'il vous connaîtraient pas là ils ont
vu tout de suite qui vous étiez du monde
mais alors on vous connaît beaucoup
mieux grâce à une biographie intitulée
rené dumont une vie saisie par
l'écologie qui paraît dans la collection
au vif chez stock qui est signée de jean
paul besset et josiane est un travail
qui a dû vous réjouir les biographies
c'est un travail magnifique il ya
vraiment non pas seulement l'étude de
relais du monde l'étude du siècle
l'étude du siècle au point de vue de des
trois combats que je mène le combat
pacifiste combat tiers-mondiste et
combat écologiste et puis aussi toute
votre votre parcours votre parcours
d'ingénieur agronome votre parcours de
deux rebelles puisque c'est le terme il
faut employer alors comme un oncle alors
on va parler du livre de philippe meric
mais hier il propose des portraits et
souvent dans vos portraits vous comparez
les hommes politiques à des personnages
littéraires ou de bandes dessinées alors
je vous ai demandé à qui vous pourriez
comparer rené dumont en venant ici je
pensais quand on était un peu dans la
même situation que les personnages d'une
bande dessinée de morris et goscinny qui
s'appelle la diligence alors dans la
diligence et plusieurs personnages est
l'un de ces personnages est un grand
personnage maigre avec un est long et
des cheveux blancs et un chapeau noir
qui passe au début pour un pasteur et
puis à la fin on s'aperçoit qu'il
n'entendait pas il me semblait que rené
dumont aurait pu faire dans la diligence
ce personnage là qu'un double glace mais
on retrouvera les autres aussi on peut
un peu on verra alors j'ai appris quand
même dans ce livre que vous êtes quand
même une vocation tardive de l'écologie
parce que votre biographe dit que vous
avez été vous êtes ingénieur agronome et
que notamment après légué à l'est après
la guerre vous avez été je le cite un
propagandiste actif de la révolution
agricole à base d'exode rural d'engrais
chimiques et de tracteurs rugissants en
1945 on avait fait en france en 1945 on
ne naît pas à manger en france
suffisamment donc il fallait augmenter
la production en 1945 les écrits
écologistes avaient pas apparu moi j'ai
appris des colis dans les assaillants
américains de 1967 aux environs bon
avant avant cette notion d'écologie
n'est pas dégagé c'est une soupe enfin
il était connu mais quelques
spécialistes oui mais vous étiez à ce
moment là pour l'intensification de la
production et crée actuellement j'ai
gardé attention les égoïsmes leurs
proches je n'ai pas connu la révolution
verte en inde
l'asie actuellement les certains échos
l'audition va supprimer tous les engrais
chimiques en inde en chine moi j'ai dit
j'ai 300 millions d'asiatiques qui
meurent de faim demain plat il faut
étudier le passage oui c'est il faut pas
être sectaire il faut être ceux du lait
il faut un chrono mais responsable mais
alors et c'est vrai que votre biographe
a raison d'insister sur votre
appartenance au monde agricole et sur
votre qualité d'ingénieur agronome et
c'est pour cela bien entendu que à la
fois vous vous êtes passionné par le
tiers-monde et que vous défendez le
tiers-monde je défends le tien monde je
défends les paysans du monde qui est les
plaisirs les plus démunis les
prolétaires des temps modernes c'était
plus les ouvriers de grande cuisine sans
les exclus d'ici et surtout les appels
tiers-monde vous êtes dit il fasciné par
le théâtre par les acteurs et j'ai été
oui j'ai été content quand j'ai été
nommé assistant l'institut agronomique
prendre mon métier professeur j'estimais
que le métier de proxy vers métier de
comédien donc il faut que j'apprenne le
métier avec les comédiens alors c'était
l'époque 1933 de louis jouvet de charles
dullin de pitoeff et de gaston petit là
la gta pour dire à l'atelier applaudir
ses auteurs là mais ensuite quand
j'étais pris par mon métier alors les
plus une seconde alors je commençais à
21 oui mais elle la semaine dernière ah
bon oui mais suffit j'ai fini maintenant
c'est un média qui vivent donc je peux
maintenant reprendre ne peut reposer un
peu et donc aller au théâtre a très bien
mais a quand même vous avez quelque
chose de comédien en vous parce que on
vous voit toujours avec votre pull rouge
se savait que vous viendriez avec ce
pull rouge mais ça c'est les techniciens
de la télévision à 114 utilisé avec un
pool rouge que bon je ne portais pas
mais ils m'ont dit c'est ce qui se
détache à la télévision bon alors à
brides au caire et oui tout simplement
et oui ça serait vachement mieux puisque
les autres et est donc marcus ou poule
rouge et donc on remarque depuis lors le
pull rouge et en même temps donc le
téléspectateur détachera mieux vos
propos parce qu'il vous verra mieux et
quand je me promène dans paris oui si je
n'ai pas le pool rouge on me dit moins
souvent bonjour
oui c'est important oui et alors ça
c'est le cas nous avait apporté ainsi
kmc d'une canne que j'ai achetée à un
berger sur le bord du nil à à ce mot
alors il m'a fait un prix raisonnable et
quand je lui ai acheté manille mais
pourquoi tu acheté cette vieille cannes
et tu me la payer deux fois plus cher
qu'une gamme neuves mais qui parce que
comme tu as porté est là pour moi
infiniment plus valeur dix fois plus
alors qu'une 15,9 à arrêter leur si ça
il y avait un copain à côté de lui c'est
ça j'ai eu trop d'argent à la fin je
partage
là ils me donnent une leçon oui c'est
d'autres d'argent
c'est à cause leçon que j'ai apporté ma
canne alors bon et alors vous l'avez là
bien entendu bien qu'elle ne servait à
rien parce qu'ici on est là aussi mais
ça c'est un peu le comédien en vous
membres dont j'ai besoin de laisser l'as
si grenier et jean paul besset dit que
vous aimez théâtralisée vos
interventions y parle même après votre
propos d'une pédagogie de l'outrance
simplement pour faire passer les idées
il faut quelquefois les jeux prévus un
peu brutalement oui ce qui explique que
vous êtes brouillée quand même avec
beaucoup de gens dans le monde même les
une énumération de gens enfin de gens de
deux chefs charismatiques du tiers-monde
avec qui vous êtes brouiller l'écouté il
m'appelle je voulais je leur donne des
conseils m'écoute pas je leur dis ce que
je pense c'est elle qui se brouille avec
moi c'est pas moi qui me revient que
fidel castro dont il m'a considéré comme
persona non grata moi je suis prêt à
retourner demain à cuba oui mais oui
mais dans le livre on voit très bien que
de temps en temps quand même vous aimez
les insultes et insulté bon à
insulter ce n'est pas
idiot par exemple président du cam on a
dit un jour qu'il avait insulté mensah
mon ami robert bureau qui lui conseille
de murray invités du moment cité voilà
comment ils robert bureau mais c'est pas
possible oui il est venu voir sa cravate
évident que quand je vais dans le
tiers-monde le port de la cravate se
pose un homme comme que l'on l'homme
comme
le contraire de l'indigène le compte n
d'autochtones au contraire des paysans
donc je tente pas de signes de cette
valorisation bourgeoise avec donc c'est
mal reçue elle s'est mal reçue par les
fêtes temps en temps vous quand même
vous dit à des gens ou lors donc en
priorité alors évidemment ils le
prennent très mal j'ai simplement dit
ahidjo que je revenais du nord cameroun
j'avais vu les paysans de son pays aux
côtés de garoua qui pays d'origine et
que j'avais calculé qu'un paysan du nord
cameroun mettez 36 ans pour gagner
autant qu'un parlementaire de yaoundé en
six mois de hausse de 2,0 en plus si moi
tiens ça fait un mois et demi de travail
alors j'ai terminé je me suis dit que
j'avais là une assistance et de lampes
octobre soit 161 oui j'ai terminé en
disant monsieur le président ça ne rend
pas 36 ans s'il a pu me fusil avec ses
yeux avec du chômage y est il a dit
quand je serai président du monde
remettra plus les pieds au cameroun
c'est bien ce qui s'est passé il peut
remettre les pieds au qu'amour et
sammour parce que tu étais plus là et
jean paul besset raconte que vous voulez
s'est invitée dans des banquets et puis
au beau milieu du banquet vous dites
vous mange trop c'est une fête un
scandale j'ai fait un scandale elle a
fait plusieurs scandales oui j'avais
fait plusieurs jeunes avaient fait 1 au
caire j'en ai fait faillir au caire il y
avait quatre plats de viande successives
alors les dames sont servis du quatrième
place et moi je me suis tourné vers la
maîtresse de maison jeudi avec les
paysans égyptiens et mangent de la
viande qu'une fois par mois en moyenne
vous permettez que je ne parle pas alors
les dames avaient leur quatrième place
verte de la race est à ne pas le manger
et l'attaché culturel de l'ambassade de
france qui étaient là qui marque on dit
le duo du mot quand je pense que moi je
peux pas en faire autant ben oui chacun
son métier
moi je suis pas attaché culturel donc je
peux me permettre de dire ce que je
pense à elles et en temps vous aimez ça
avec naturellement un sas et ça c'est
sûr et ça c'est sûr ça vous êtes mu
c'est sûr et est toujours dans les gens
qui boivent trop alors on a entendu là
quelques-uns des motifs de votre
indignation mais rebelle vous êtes un
rebelle c'est évident mais vous êtes
rebelles en dehors déjà d'aider des
sujets cooney d'aborder vous êtes
rebelles à quoi encore chez bon rebelles
la guerre oui alors là la guerre du
golfe c'est bien mais alors on à paris
on n'a pas la sale guerre depuis voyez
depuis le 10 octobre 1914 oui j'avais 10
ans et demi on en parlera on en parlera
de ça bon alors rebelles au tiers-monde
rebelles à d'écart entre nous et le
tiers-monde oui actuellement 15% de la
population c'est les nantis un milliard
de nantis un milliard de nantis c'est
amérique nord europe de l'ouest japon
australie les émirats pétroliers 15% de
la population ont 80 % des ressources un
milliard de nantis et à côté il ya un
milliard d'exclus ceux qui ont faim
l'écart de niveau de vie entre le
meilleur nantis ami avec lui nous dit
cela nous des programmes nationaux 150
un bon et chaque année c'était car
augmente bon ben vous quoi ils vont
accepter de crever la bouche pour lui
mais alors ça prouve que tout ce que
vous faites depuis 20 ans ça sert à rien
ça veut dire que ça veut dire que je
n'ai pas été suivi ça veut dire que
l'écart augmente c'est à dire que les
risques alors le tiers-monde se révolte
comment par la drogue
même l'afrique est maintenant touchés
par les vagues une audi fottorino bon
bah par le terrorisme que nous on a des
explosifs instables bon alors on parle
beaucoup des explosifs des deux avions
on oublie de dire que il ya des formes
de terrorisme d'état qui tue chaque jour
qui est ce l'amour l'embargo en irak tue
chaque jour pendant 500 à 800 enfants
vous êtes tous les jours vous ne vous
êtes pas désespérer de voir que
finalement tout ce que vous dites tout
ce que vous faites tout votre vous voyez
à chaque année ça sert pas à grand chose
est sûre sert pas à grand chose il ya eu
la digue la décolonisation mais
évidemment elle n'a pas des suivis par
la dépendance de ce qu'on espérait non
on marque des points comme ça
on marque les points d'ombré alors voici
au relais du mois de cul molina dans
lequel on vous voit pendant votre
campagne électorale c'était donc en 1974
en bretagne et je rappelle que vous
étiez alors le candidat écologique de là
à la présidence de la république
il était 11h 15 hier le candidat
écologiste rené dumont se posait à
lorient nouvelle étape de sa campagne
sur le terrain
en voiture après un premier meeting au
cours duquel il devait déclarer qu'il ne
se désisteraient pas avant le premier
tour afin de mesurer la prise de
conscience des problèmes écologiques
rené dumont tenait une conférence de
presse pique nique au bord de la laïta
pour accuser les pollueurs de la rivière
quelques minutes pour se relaxer d'une
façon tout à fait écologique avant
d'animer un meeting champêtre rappelant
la forêt lieu prévu pour l'implantation
d'une marina
il ya des gens qui sont plus
raisonnables que nous il y a deux mois
le gouvernement des pays-bas a interdit
toute nouvelle construction d'autoroutes
le jour vous voudrez frais contre
l'autoroute des gens
ce fut aussi pour le professeur
l'occasion d'un proviseur un petit cours
d'agronomie avec les élèves d'une classe
de mer qui passait par là
et ensuite la traditionnelle promenade à
vélo moyens de transport dont il a fait
on le sait son arme symbolique favorite
la voiture ça pue ça pollue ça rend con
après un crochet par l'île longue base
des sous marins atomiques le candidat se
rendait à brest si nous continuons à
l'évolution actuelle de la population et
de la production industrielle démentiel
nous allons à l'effondrement total de
l'autre notre planète de la vie sur la
terre vers le milieu du siècle prochain
et finalement vos discours n'ont pas
changé un rené dumont parce que contre
les autoroutes déjà y avait un temps
déjà vous
la situation s'est aggravée s'aggrave
tous les jours et si on nous écoute pas
bien l'humanité perdue nation population
aussi edward goldsmith dire l'écrire
lille qui s'appelle 5000 jours pour
sauver la planète mon ami lessard brawn
qui dirige l'institut de washington 10
dans dix ans les dés seront jetés bon
mais oui mais oui mais votre biographie
que vous êtes un cassandre propre
professionnel et que vous annoncez
toujours déjà leur art dont je répète
j'ai là de tous les livres qui monte à
prouver la gelée sur pop in a trop le
malin brut lang a travaillé quatre ans
pour les nations unies pour établir un
rapport sur l'environnement et le
développement et tout ceci tout ce que
je fais simplement de rappeler ce que
ces chercheurs font moi je suis un
vulgarisateur évidemment rené dumont
gueye était bien embêté si vous aviez
été élu président de la république en 74
quand même nom mais je ne courait pas de
risque oui oui c'est vrai je serai
jamais vous savez j'ai eu deux fois plus
de voix que le pen un jour là à l'époque
oui deux fois plus de voix que j'ai eu
un million j'ai trois ans 35 des voix et
le pen venu de moitié exactement ah oui
mais relais depuis la barre d'adressé
lui un mail nous sommes tous les deux
écologistes et front national à 15%
c'est vraiment nous ne sommes pas 15 2 x
7 hélas
peut-être que pure verbard impasse
mignon tout plein air aux gens des
médias est peut-être là avant vous
connaissez vous avez déjà travaillé fort
mais avec renault on s'est battu le 14
juillet 1989 quand on voulait que la de
la bastille la prise de la bastille soit
fêtée par les celtes les feuilles les
plus riches du monde le g7 nous avons
les pardons il ya des états les plus
pauvres la renault a fait une chanson sa
place de la bastille tu es le 9 juillet
selon laquelle chanson non un récital
genève hug f1 avec plein d'organisation
n'avait en rien concerné en de
protestation contre la dette l'apartheid
et les colonies mais c'est que tester
contre la tenue en plein sommet du
bicentenaire qui était censé célébrer
les camps et sans culottes protester
contre la venue à paris du g7 des sept
pays les plus riches du monde qui sont
responsables de la misère de
plus de quatre cinquièmes de l'humanité
vous organisez la pourquoi pas organiser
le sommet des sept pays les plus pauvres
du monde sait ce qu'il avait du monde un
coupé ah oui c'est ça je sais c'était
quel pays bangladesh sûrement il y avait
les philippines et au bangladesh il y
avait le burkina faso il y avait en mai
malgré tin
le brésil le brésil le brésil vous
publiez en même temps aux éditions du
seuil un livre cette guerre nous
déshonneur alors bon vous avez rappelé
que vous habitez contre cette guerre et
que vous revenez d'irak vous avez déjà
nous avait donné quelques informations
et vous êtes absolument indigne et
maintenant c'est un scandale d'abord
d'avoir accepté de faire la guerre alors
qu'on pourrait négocier ensuite la
guerre comme elle a été faite le
bombardement qui a détruit à bagdad tout
le réseau d'eau tout réseau dit
d'électricité qui a laissé cinq millions
d'habitants sans eau potable pandémie
mais ça c'est la guerre
dont les états unis ont signé la
convention de genève lisez la convention
de genève de 1947 et le complément en
1977 qui interdit de bombarder les
objets civils a interdit de bombarder
les soldats en déroute ils ont reparlé
soldats deux joueurs belle 6,5 feu sur
la route de commun et non il ya une
série de crimes de guerre il ya tout un
livre que je peux vous envoyer work
prime de ramsey clark ramsey clark a été
en irak pendant la guerre pour témoigner
que la guerre ne faisait pas suivant les
les règles de la guerre n'ont pas été
respectées et on a bombardé parmi les
plus vieux monument de l'histoire de
l'humanité on a bombardé le paradis
terrestre non c'est un scandale vingt
sept cas cette guerre nous déshonneur
mais alors quand le gouvernant membres
de la légion d'honneur moi je peux pas
accepter la légion d'honneur de la part
d'un gouvernement qui s'était déshonoré
lui mais rené dumont votre biographe
jean paul besset fait remarquer que vous
avez eue pendant la guerre 40 45 une
attitude pacifiste total c'est à dire
que vous êtes vous n'êtes pas devenu
collaborateur n'est pas été résistant
non plus c'est à dire vous n'avez rien
fait pardon à ses ce qu'il y attardons
pas d'accord mais attardons ce qui lie
le 15 octobre 1940 un seul professeur
assure yannick a protesté contre la
nouvelle leur professeur israël est sur
les lois lead j'étais le seul à avoir
dit dans tous les élèves je proteste
contre la commedia destitution de wade
mon directeur je le fais je me fais
appeler en dehors du mot si vous
continuez comme ça vous aura les armes
et administratifs j'ai un produit son
effet que j'avais envisagé les hormis
autres qu'administratif mais de là comme
non violent allez dire on va attaquer un
allemand dans la rue bon celui qui a
attaqué qui a tué à nantes
officiellement il ya eu ensuite 50
fusillé achète aux voyants non mais
d'accord mais en fait tout le monde on
pouvait faire la résistance comme ça
simplement en portant du courrier on
n'était pas obligé généralement j'ai
apporté durant six mois j'ai reçu chez
moi ton libre et jean qui était alors
maintenant parce que votre biographe dit
ceci du monde c'est certes pas sali les
mains mais lui qui s'est identifiée au
grand combat universel de la justice
contre la barbarie n'at-il pas manqué là
un sacré rendez vous de l'histoire en se
comportant comme un petit français
peut-être potable mais j'ai fait quelque
chose quand même nom mais le plus
important c'est qu'actuellement il y a
dans le monde une injustice sans cesse
croissante et c du code cette injustice
nous sommes les profiteurs cette
injustice 15% de la population qui ont
80 % des ressources ils sont en train
non seulement d'avoir ruiné le
tiers-monde nous sommes en train de
détruire tous les climats du tiers-monde
vraiment jamais il n'ya eu un niveau
d'injustice
les lakers 108 meilleur média qu'est ce
que est ce que vous êtes d'accord
j'ai lu la biographie de monsieur dumont
dans laquelle le biographe explique que
vous étiez favorable à munich en 38 ou
moins et une citation de vos revenus
temps 38 g/t munichois l'eau les
socialistes aussi en 1930
qu'est-ce qu'on les derniers se dire
qu'il ya une logique il ya deux choses
dans la position de monsieur du mans sur
la guerre il ya le nom absolue à la
guerre il y ait ensuite le nom au
mensonge qui a eu lieu qui a encore lieu
aujourd'hui qui a été le mensonge de la
guerre propre bien évidemment pas eu de
guerre propre et c'est un mensonge qui
dure encore aujourd'hui non mais si vous
laissez mes yeux il ya eu la guerre
d'indochine ya la guerre d'algérie eux
ils ont invité des crimes non simplement
s'était pris avec moi je n'ai pas du
tout l'été de votre de votre opinion au
moment de la déclaration de guerre je
pensais que
toutes choses égales par ailleurs il
n'était pas possible de laisser saddam
hussein contrôler pourcentage aussi
important des ressources pétrolières que
donc il fallait la guerre ensuite
possible sur le mensonge sur la guerre
propre et sur le fait qu'ils étaient qui
est une chose grave que ce mensonge dure
encore eu naturel qu en réalité on a on
n'a aucune idée même approximative la
guerre quinze mille unités près comme si
cette unité était négligeable du nombre
de morts il ya eu un miracle et
effectivement le problème moi j'étais à
la fois pour la guerre et la première
chronique que j'ai fait une fois la
guerre déclenchée cet été contre les
généraux qui étaient dans tous les
studios parce que la pensée qu'il faut
faire la guerre comme il je crois qu'il
fallait la faire au moment de munich
comme je crois qu'il a fallu le faire au
moment de miracles et que les généraux
face l'information là il ya deux choses
qui ne tiennent aucun sens parce que si
on fait la guerre si on a fait la guerre
contre l'irak c'était au nom de la
démocratie alors si c'est pour faire une
démocratie à la sauce galonnés qui
arrive à cacher cette histoire immédiate
qui a été ce
la quantité assez choquant mais c'est
une violence président et on a ramassé
tel embargo ou la guerre sainte vierge
et jean marc et du monde arabe rené
dumont d'un deuxième partie du livre
vous préconisez quelques initiatives à
prendre pour briser le vieil ordre
économique et politique mondiale mais
est-ce que ça ça relève pas de l'utopie
york mais l'utopie actuellement si on
accepte l'heure actuelle on va on va la
mort la faucheuse quelque chose alors on
me dit que c'est de l'utopie mais
actuellement si on continue l'ordre
actuel le libéralisme économique
intégral 1 l'écart entre le nord et le
sud ne cesse pas d'augmenter 2 les
risques de guerre ne cesse pas
d'augmenter 3 l'environnement est
démolie tous les jours
donc nous allons actuellement notre
chemin nous mène tout droit à la mort
vous l'avez j'accepte de sa non non
alors alors huit pieds bon l'utopie très
bien les dix questions oui voilà votre
mot préféré en écumant
liberté pour les femmes et les enfants
surtout le mot que vous détestez la
misère la faim votre drogue favorite le
travail le son le bruit que vous aimez
le beaulieu russo et le son le bruit que
vous détestez le voyez canaux et des
bombes votre juron gros mot blasphème
favoris ou peut détenir un mou femmes
pour illustrer un nouveau billet de
banque jean jaurès qui a été tellement
méprisés par les gommes lisses pu par
les socialistes le métier que vous
n'auriez pas aimé faire les fabricants
de bombes atomiques
laplante l'arbre où l'animal dans lequel
vous aimeriez être réincarné non le
requin et ça ça n'existe pas c'est un
mythe dangereux alors je refuse à samy
dangereux ah oui ah bon oui pourquoi
alors que c'est d'une légende hélène et
légendes sont merveilleuses oui
attention continue n'exige pas ensuite
de nous plier à certains ordres comme le
catholicisme par exemple ah bon le baht
ma dernière question si dieu existe
qu'aimeriez vous après votre mort
l'entendre vous dire il n'y a pas de
tensions ici à très bien
[Musique]